the southern nevada health district and
clark county officials are hosting a
preview of the covit 19 vaccination
drive-through clinic
it's opening at the texas station hotel
and casino reporter madison kimbrough
explains
yes this new brand new drive-through
clinic will be open on tuesday
but tomorrow they're giving media a tour
of the new location
it's all a part of the health districts
and county's efforts to offer more
locations for people to get vaccinated
as the community moves towards fully
reopening and removing capacity
restrictions
and social distancing requirements
drive-through clinics are extremely
convenient and a great way to get
yourself checked and vaccinated
especially if you want to beat the
crowds and as for those that have yet to
get their vaccine shot
the hope is that the clinic will make it
as easy as possible for them
given the slowdown and vaccination
interest and hesitancy that's been out
there
we could be looking at 10 weeks or more
before we actually get
across that finish line and what that
means is
casino capacity theater capacity
stadiums arenas everything capacity-wise
will not get to 100 percent by the by
the rules have been laid out by the
county
and i believe the state also has a hand
in that until we reach that mark
appointments start at 7 a.m and last
until noon seven days a week
this will be a six-week clinic to
accommodate a full cycle of first and
second dose appointments of the pfizer
vaccine
and the drive-through clinic will be
located on the first floor of the
resort's parking garage that you're
seeing right now on the south side of
the property
and as of now vaccine appointments and
covet 19 testing are also available
but walk-in covet 19 testing is
available
as resources allow so make sure you look
out for that reporting in north las
vegas madison kimbrough 8 news now